are you familiar
with
after the 2014 revolution or coup or
whatever you want to call it the there
was a recorded phone call with victoria
nuland
and another um
high up senator or something in the u.s
there was a recorded phone call between
them and victoria nuland is talking
about
two people and who would be the best fit
to be the president of the ukraine next
and she's basically saying yes i think
we think this guy's the best fit we just
need to sign off from biden who is who
was victoria noland
victoria newland is the lady who was
just interviewed in front of congress
the other day by
um
i think it was marco rubio talking about
chemical weapons being in the ukraine
she's been she's been deeply involved
with the ukraine for a very long time
neoconservative her husband's a
neoconservative
um her husband is uh robert kagan okay
and there was a there was a recorded
phone call with her talking about who
would be the next best fit for president
of the ukraine after that coup
well okay but that's talk and
it i it i don't think it is possible for
the american government to install
a a president in a country like ukraine
do you think
during that during that revolution um
when the opposition was going up against
um the police force of the ukraine the
the are you where like this the snipers
and all the people that were that were
getting killed oh sure
the war was ongoing uh and i uh i told
you about uh
uh the the journalist um
who
who told me who who was in charge who
was the
the the correspondent for for
the guardian he wrote a book it's called
the long hangover and that has a lot
a lot of stuff is in there about
the ongoing back and forth between
uh
ukraine or within ukraine and russia and
so forth and and it it was deadly for a
long time
there is no hint in in his writing that
the americans had
really anything to do with it the guy is
really good
i'd be really interested to hear your
thoughts if if we could find it austin
could you find the youtube video
of the recorded phone call with victoria
newland
talking about the next leader of ukraine
uh she mentions biden
now biden was not in the picture he was
the vice president
it was obama was the president he was
the vice president at the time oh okay
biden was in charge of ukraine yes yes i
i
remember that now and then he had his
son his son was a board member of one of
the big energy companies that was formed
right in the ukraine
assistant secretary of state for
european affairs victoria newland and
the u.s ambassador to ukraine jeffrey
piet
questions of credibility are being
raised after a private chat between two
top us diplomats was leaked online i
think yaz is the guy who's got the
economic experience the governing
experience he's he's the guy you know
what he needs is clich and tony book on
the outside i i just think creech going
in he's going to be at that level
working for yakiniku it's just not going
to work
yeah no i think that's i think that's
right okay
good would you want us to try to set up
a call with him here's your next step
sullivan's come back to me uh vfr saying
you need biden and i said probably
tomorrow for an attaboy and they get the
deeds to stick clearly
so you had this remarkable phone call
where you have these two senior
officials of the us government
apparently talking about a coup or how
they were planning to restructure the
government of ukraine
[ __ ] the eu
exactly i'm not saying the whole [ __ ]
the eu feels that way the there's there
is division on this but the
neoconservative element wants very much
to change the strategic dynamic
in eastern europe
by the way this documentary was just
banned from youtube last week this is an
oliver stone documentary
oh really yes
so you know when when i hear neocons
being involved uh
the whole story has more credibility
because uh
the neocons and and i think they
they're not they weren't they're not all
republicans
right is it no yeah hillary clinton
yes there are war mongers and on both
sides and and they're
they're hawks and they're irresponsible
and you want to know something crazy
about that lady victoria newland her
husband if you could google her husband
robert kagan
one of the biggest advocates of the iraq
war
[Music]
so anyways the documentary is
fascinating and it goes into the whole
the whole thing and they talk about
aging provocateurs being a part of that
revolution in ukraine
killing cops and killing ukrainian cops
and killing um
parts of the resistance that that sounds
very similar to some of the worst uh
activities that uh was conducted by the
cia for instance in chile right
i mean that was that was the cia
playbook right yes and that was not
supposed to be repeated
now if
if this
grows this is could become one of the
biggest scandal
in history of the united states but yeah
we don't have enough to go by as to
whether they actually followed through
on the talk
there's the you know signals
yeah and then biden biden was in charge
of ukraine but right but but biden was
never a hawk was he i don't think so
um
yeah hillary clinton was secretary of
state and you
don't know what
whether barack obama had an a an
independent opinion
uh whether they saw eye to eye on these
things
hey
you're scaring me but i'm i'm at the
edge of
my
my sandbox that says competence
right
well in the interviews you know he he
talk he discusses this with putin and
putin is very much aware of all of it
and he says you know this is what we're
used to this has been going on forever
um
during that revolution he let the forget
the name of the current president that
was there he let him go to russia
um and the eu backed president came and
then took over
um
took over ukraine anyways and then and
then
you know
it's scary it's it's it's
it's dark
but then you take the the article that
he wrote it's uh about 6 000 words it's
a pretty lengthy rather
uh elaborate article about his plans
uh that doesn't say anything about
you know responding to the
to the evil uh united states it says
this is my vision right so that vision
was there before true
and and even even if uh we monkey in the
ukraine that still does not excuse what
putin has done
to
innocent women and children right
there's no justification for that
now
we're doing what are what is the u.s
doing specifically like seizing the
yachts of these oligarchs and going
after the oligarchs how does that
[ __ ] or how does that hurt putin
no no the oligarchs well
yeah they become somewhat feckless once
once they all leave the country if they
are actually in opposition to the war
they may
lose control of
what they currently still control in in
russia
i think what what
what hurts more is uh
uh
uh limiting the ability of of russia to
uh be involved in international commerce
i mean they already have shortages all
over the place right right uh and wi-fi
i mean they don't have they can't go to
the grocery store they can't watch
netflix and uh you can go to mcdonald's
yeah well
this this is inconvenience but uh
i don't know if the entire swift system
has been uh
russia hasn't
locked been locked out of that if so
they can't do any commerce in uh
because you know
have you ever made money abroad
no so when
i have
euros right so you you need to get a
swift account to get money transferred
from from there to here so this this is
swift is the system that enables
international commerce
and i think at least partially it has
been blocked
to the extent the um
europe's still buying gas and oil
that may still be be working but but the
russians are feeling it
and in
in his most recent speech uh putin has
acknowledged it and he said well yeah
this we're going to have this this and
this is all going to be pretty bad but
we need to get through this
to uh
it's for the greater good of the country
and uh
believe it or not most of the russians
are behind them so if people think you
know oh yeah there's mass demonstrations
and he will be toppled by an angry
populist
not going to happen
not going to happen no because uh
there has been too much uh propaganda
whether that is new whether that is
right or has uh has roots in in reality
or not the the the majority of the the
russian people believe
in the propaganda that comes out of
putin's government
and that's it it's an ideology it's
called russian nationalism
and he's he's been pursuing that ever
since he
became the head of state
[Laughter]